MAY EIGHTH.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
FROM SEEN A LOT OF ACTIVITY THIS
MORNING.
I WANT PEOPLE TO REALIZE THAT WE
HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
BILLS TODAY -- IF THERE IS A NOT
A NEED -- TO SPEAK ON YOUR BILL
THAT.
THAT IS A WOULD BE APPRECIATED --
THAT'S A LOT OF BILLS TO GET
THROUGH.
NOTING THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM --
WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
STARTING WITH MISTER BLOOM.
MR BLOOM YOU'LL HAVE.
YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT ON YOUR
SUSPENSE COMMITTEE HEARING
[inaudible]
THAT'S ALRIGHT.
MADAM CHAIR AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS QUICKLY I
HOPE -- UNDERSTANDS IMPORTANT
BILL TEO AND IT IS AN IMPORTANT
BELT THAT.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THAT --
WE'RE CUED UP TO MAKE THIS AS
QUICK AS POSSIBLE AND A MANAGER
MEMBERS -- CHILD'S ABILITY TO
HEAR SHOULD NOT BE DETERMINED BY
THEIR FAMILY INCOME YET HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF FAMILIES
WHO HAVE TO PAY FOR THEIR
CHILD'S HEARING AIDS OUT OF
POCKET OR SIMPLY HAVE TO FOREGO
THEM ALL TOGETHER.
AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT ADDRESSES
THIS GAP AND I SHOULD POINT OUT
THAT THE COST HEARING AIDS IS --
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT BARRIER
PARENTS SEEKING TO OBTAIN THEM
FOR THEIR CHILDREN AND THESE
HEARING AIDS CAN COST UP TO SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR A PAIR
GROWING CHILDREN FREQUENTLY NEED
TO REPLACE THEM.
ACROSS THE TAPE THE STATE
FAMILIES ARE SHOULDERING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN OUT OF
POCKET MEDICAL EXPENSES THAT
SHOULD RIGHTFULLY BE COVERED BY
THEIR INSURANCE.
AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT WOULD LIFT
THIS FINANCIAL.
BURDEN OFF OF FAMILIES AT THE
COST OF ONLY A FEW CENTS PER
PLAN.
AND TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL OR ERIN SCHWAB MOTHER OF
HARD OF HEARING CHILD AND DOCTOR
DANNIELLA CARVALLO DEPARTMENT
SURGERY CHAIR AND THE DIRECTOR
OF HEARING PROGRAM.
AT RADY CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL IN
SAN DIEGO I REMIND THE WITNESSES
THAT YOU HAVE -- TWO MINUTES
EACH AND THE COMMENT SHOULD BE
AS PERTAINING TO THE FISCAL
ANALYSIS OF THIS IS THE FISCAL
NOT ON THE POLICY MATTER BEFORE
WE BEGIN THAT IF WE CAN --
ACTUALLY HAVE A AT THE THE ROLE.
AND SECRETARY.
GONZALEZ PRESENT BIGELOW.
BLOOM HERE BONTA.
CALDERON.
CARILLO YEAH CHAO.
DEEP.
EGGMAN FONG.
GABRIEL GARCIA.
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE HERE
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK [inaudible]
THIS.
ARE YOU MAY PROCEED IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS THE NOW PROVIDE HOLE
AND I'M A PEDIATRIC ONCOLOGIST
DIRECTOR OF THE HEARING PROGRAM
PLAN PROGRAM AT REGIONS HOSPITAL
SAN DIEGO.
FASTER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S AN YOU'RE GOING
TO CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CHAMPION
APPEARED HEARING DETECTION AND
INTERVENTION PROGRAM.
I'M HERE REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS RETURNS HOSPITALS
AND YOU'RE GOING ALSO SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF LET CALIFORNIA.
HERE INITIATIVE AND OVER THIRTY
ORGANIZATIONS IN SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE NINE EIGHT THE FIRST MONTHS
AND YEARS OF OUR LIVES ARE
CRUCIAN DEVELOPING THE HEARING
PATHWAYS IN OURBRAINS AND HANDS
ARE OR LANGUAGE.
THERE'S OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE
THAT THE CHILDREN DEPRIVE THE
NORMAL ACCESS CITY HERE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT SPEECH AN ORAL
LANGUAGE THE LACE.
THIS IMPACT THEIR ACADEMIC LIFE
CAUSES PROBLEMS WITH SOCIAL
INTERACTION AS WELL AS EMOTIONAL
AND PSYCHOLOGICAL DIFFICULTIES.
DEAF.
OR HARD OF HEARING CHILDREN WHO
GO UNTREATED COST OUR TAXPAYERS
UP TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN LOSS OF
PRODUCTIVITY.
BECAUSE OF THE IMPORTANCE OF
HERE IN THE EARLY MONTHS OF LIFE.
DEAR HEARING AFFECTION IN TURN
INTERVENTION PROGRAM HAS
INSTITUTED IS ONE THREE SIX
GUIDELINES SCREENING BY ONE
MONTH OF AGE DIAGNOSIS OF
HEARING LOSS WITH THREE MONTHS
OF AGE.
AND EARLY INTERVENTION AND
TREATMENT BY SIX MONTHS OF AGE.
CALIFORNIA THOSE EAT BEAUTIFUL
JOB IN SCREENING AND IDENTIFY
OUR CHILDREN WITH HEARING LOSS
BUT FAILS MISERABLY WHEN IT
COMES TO TREATING THEM.
I SEE THIS EVERY DAY WHEN I TAKE
CARE CHILDREN WHO ARE HARD OF
HEARING IT READ THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL.
I SEE THE DIFFERENCE THAT I HEAR
RATE MAKES IN THE LIVES AND
EARLY DEVELOPMENT OF THESE
CHILDREN.
HOWEVER BECAUSE ONLY ONE IN TEN
CHILDREN HAVE HEARING AIDS
COVERED BUTTER PRIVATE HEALTH
PLAN IN CALIFORNIA.
I ALSO SEE HOW DEVASTATING IT IS
FOR PARENTS WERE UNABLE TO
AFFORD THE TREATMENT THAT THEY
KNOW THEIR CHILD NEEDS.
HEARING AID COVERAGE FOR
CHILDREN IS ALREADY MANDATED IN
TWENTY FOUR OTHER STATES.
AND IT'S TIME TO LET CALIFORNIA
KIDS HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MOVE THE BILL.
IT'S ON SUSPENSE CAM OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MEDICARE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
ERIN TRIBE I'M A TRAINEE
POSITION OVER AT UC DAVIS AND
MOTHER OF TWO IDENTICAL TWIN
BOYS WHO HAVE BEEN DIAGNOSED
WITH HEARING IMPAIRMENTS -- THEY
WERE BORN AT THIRTY TWO WEEKS IN
JANUARY AND STATE IN THE ICU FOR
ABOUT TWO MONTHS SO THEY WERE
DIAGNOSED A DAY -- FOR WITH THE
GENETIC CONDITION CALLED
CONGENITAL HYPOTHYROIDISM AND
THIS IS WHAT LED TO THEIR
HEARING LOSS.
WE ARE LUCKY BECAUSE WE DO HAVE
INSURANCE HOWEVER THE DOCTORS
JUST HOWEVER AFTER THE DOCTORS
DISCOVERED THE HEARING LOSS.
I FOUND OUT THAT MY INSURANCE
DOES NOT COVER HEARING AID. FOR
MY BOYS THE COST OF ONE
PEDIATRIC HEARING AID IN ONE EAR
IS SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS.
AND THAT'S FOR ME IT WILL BE
ABOUT SIXTY EIGHT HUNDRED
DOLLARS.
THE COST DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
MOLD THAT ARE REQUIRED TO HELP --
TO TED KINDA TRANSMIT THOSE
HEARING AIDS THAT COST OF
SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER YEAR
AND THAT HAS TO BE REPLACED
EVERY THREE MONTHS AS THESE
CHILDREN ARE DEVELOPING.
SO AT THIS POINT EVERY THREE
MONTHS I HAVE ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS IN COSTS FOR MY
CHILDREN TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CONTINUE TO HEAR AND DEVELOP
LANGUAGE APPROPRIATELY.
DUE TO THE HIGH COST MISS BUT
ESPECIALLY WITH TWIN BOYS.
I HAVE TRIED TO SEE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE THIS BILL WILL HELP
ALLEVIATE THESE FINANCIAL
CONCERNS -- SO I ENCOURAGE YOU
TO PLEASE PASS THIS BILL FIVE
NINETY EIGHT TO HELP FAMILIES
LIKE US FACING THESE FINANCIAL
DISCIPLINE DIFFICULTIES.
AND PAY FOR THE HEARING AIDS TO
ALLOW THESE CHILDREN HERE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
IF YOU CAN COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE STATE YOUR NAME AT
YOUR ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE
ONE AND YOUR POSITION AND THAT'S
IT.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS MICHELLE
MARCINIAK I HAVE A DAUGHTER --
WHO WEARS HEARING AIDS -- I'M CO
CHAIR OF LET CALIFORNIA KIDS
HERE WE SUPPORT THIS THERE'S
THIRTY THREE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAVE SIGNED ON THROUGHOUT THE
STATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
JOHNSON CLAIMED SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME.
ONE CAN YOU PLEASE SUPPORT.
FIVE NINETY MOURNERS DAD.
AND IT'S TIME NOW TO LET
CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE.
THANK YOU AYE AYE.
AND I EIGHT I LOVE WHEN PEOPLE
COME IN SO THANK YOU BUT THIS IS
A I HAVE LITERALLY TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE BILL SO YOU CAN
IMAGINE WE ARE ONLY GOING TO
ALLOW.
YOUR NAME.
IF YOUR ORGANIZATION OF YOUR
PRIVATE YOUR POSITION ON THE
BILL I'M SORRY SO IF WE CAN
QUICKLY GET THROUGH THESE.
MAYBE ASSESSMENT CULTURE LIKE
CALIFORNIA KIDS HERE RETIRED
DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING IN FACT
TEACHER I SUPPORT.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT NANCY SEAGER
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
FOR HANDS AND VOICES PLEASE
SUPPORT AB FIVE NINETY EIGHT LET
SKYLINK LIKE ACCOUNTING HILL
THANK YOU.
AGAIN I DON'T I I DO NOT I LOVE
WHEN PEOPLE COME UP HERE IN AND
POLICY COMMITTEES IS VERY
IMPORTANT BUT WE LITERALLY NEED
YOU TO SAY YOUR NAME.
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE RIGHT NOW YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT LINE SO I ASSUME IT'S
SUPPORT SO PLEASE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S CAPRICE THIS IS MY
DAUGHTER.
A FEE AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT OF
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NIKKI THIS IS MY
DAUGHTER EMORY AND WE SUPPORT A.
B..
FIVE NINETY EIGHT MY NAME IS
JOHN I WONDER LEE THESE ARE MY
DAUGHTER'S.
CAITLYN CASSIE AND KERA AND WE
SUPPORT AB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
PAULA REYES POOR AB.
FIVE NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU. FOR
ENDING THIS IS MY SON BENJAMIN
WHO IS HARD OF HEARING AND WE
SUPPORT -- A FIVE NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU.
HI DOCTOR MICHELLE CHRISTY FROM
NO LIMITS FOR DEAF CHILDREN
SUPPORT.
FIVE NINE EIGHT THANK YOU.
HI I'M KIMBERLY WHERE AND I'M A
MOM I SUPPORT AB FIVE NINE EIGHT
THANK YOU PERFECT THING CAM.
HELLO MY NAME IS COVINA MILLER.
AND I AM A TEACHER THE DEAF HARD
OF HEARING IT SUCKS CITY SCHOOLS
AND I A SUPPORT AB FIVE MANY
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS HEIDI BRING TEN
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA STATE
PTA AND MYSELF AS A DEAF AND
HARD OF HEARING PERSON.
SUPPORT OF THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DEBBIE STRAIGHTER
I'M FROM THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA KECK SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE.
I AM THE EDUCATIONAL SPECIALIST
ON THE CRUISE SO FAMILY CENTER
FOR CHILDHOOD COMMUNICATION IN
SUPPORT WE SUPPORT AB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU.
I'M CRISTINA BARBER EDUCATIONAL
AUDIOLOGIST IN PLASTER COUNTY
AND I SUPPORT.
THE CHICANE REPRESENTING THE
CHAT CENTER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JASON SCHWAB IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
PERFECT.
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING I'M JENNIFER ALLIED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
HEALTH PLANS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL THIS BILL WILL
INCREASED -- HEALTH INSURANCE
PREMIUMS BY THIRTEEN POINT EIGHT
MILLION EVERY YEAR WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT A INTRODUCED PREMIUM
TOTAL OF OVER.
EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
THIS YEAR AND SO -- WELL WE
SYMPATHIZE WITH THIS GROUP --
THERE IS A PROCESS TO ESTABLISH
MANDATES THROUGH THE SELECTION
OF THE ESSENTIAL HEALTH BENEFITS --
THE MOST RECENT -- PLAN
SELECTION THAT WAS -- DETERMINED
BY THE LEGISLATURE DID NOT
INCLUDE HEARING AIDS AND SO CAN
WE ARE.
EXTREMELY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TOTALITY OF OF ALL THE MANDATES
THAT ARE IN THE LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE TO KNOW ME
ASSURE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE DO NOT THE FILE AT THIS TIME.
YOU SEEN NO QUESTIONS.
FROM THE COMMITTEE WOULD YOU
LIKE CLOSE MISTER.
ONE THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
INDULGENCE -- LOOK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM.
IS CONOR DOT WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS -- YOU HAVE TWO
BILLS THAT WE'RE GONNA HERE
TODAY AB TWO FORTY WANTED ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS CARILLO
IN A SECOND BY A MYSTERY OF US
GREAT THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING WHEN I'M CHANNEL
MEMBERS I AM HERE TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON AB.
TWO FOUR ONE AB TWO FOUR ONE
WILL REDUCE DISPARITIES IN
HEALTH CARE BY REQUIRING
CONTINUED MEDICAL EDUCATION
COURSES TO INCLUDE CURRICULUM.
ON IMPLICIT BIAS FOR LICENSEES
UNDER THE MEDICAL BOARD
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT ASSISTANT
BOARD AND BOARD OF REGISTERED
NURSING.
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS EXPECT THE
COSTS OF THIS BILL TO BE MINOR
AND OBSERVABLE.
THE BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING
WHICH WOULD NEED TO ADOPT RED
REGULATIONS CAN INCORPORATE THE
CURRICULUM REQUIREMENTS INTO
EXISTING REGULATIONS FOR
TRACKING CONTINUING EDUCATION
COURSES I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MICHELLE EVANS OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
ALL RIGHT WHICH I CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE --
THAT BILL IS ON CALL INTO WE GET
ANOTHER DEMOCRAT HERE.
AB TWO FORTY TWO ALSO ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY DR QUIRK IN A SECOND
BY MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU AGAIN I AM PRESENTING
A. B. TWO FOUR TWO WHICH WILL
REQUIRE ATTORNEYS AND JUDGES TO
PARTAKE IN CONTINUAL EDUCATION
ON IMPLICIT BIAS EVERY THREE
YEARS AND COURT PERSONNEL EVERY
TWO YEARS.
AB TWO FOUR TWO WILL POSE MINOR
AN OBSERVABLE COSTS TO JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND THERE ARE NO COSTS
TO STATE FOR MANDATE ON
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU.
SUPPORT JERSEYS ANY SUPPORTERS
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
EYEBROWS AND SOON AS WE GET
ANOTHER DEMOCRAT HERE WE WILL
TAKE THAT OFF CALL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE NEED SOME AUTHORS
DOWN HERE THEY'RE LIKE NINETEEN
OF THEM SO -- MISTER OBERNOLTE
AS A BILL HE LIKE TO PRESENT.
MR OBERNOLTE WILL BE PRESENTING
AB FOURTEEN TWENTY IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE.
A MOTION BY MS CREE ON A SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRK WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE ALL THE
BRIEF AB -- FOURTEEN TWENTY
DRAWS CANNABIS LICENSING FEES
INTO THE SAME CATEGORY AS ON 90%
OF THE OTHER FEES ANOTHER PART
OF THE CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ESTABLISHES LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OVER THOSE FEES WHICH
I THINK IS AN APPROPRIATE THING
TO DO.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST RIVALS.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
SEEN AND WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR BIGELOW NOT
VOTING.
MR VOEPEL WELCOME BACK.
YOU WILL BE PRESENTING ON AB
THREE NINETY ONE IT ENJOYS I DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE
BILL.
WITH A MOTION BY MS CARILLO IN A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
DEFINITELY REQUEST THAT YOU
APPROVE THIS BILL.
PERFECT PRESENTATION SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
VOEPEL.
MS BURKE WOULD YOU LIKE TO GO.
YOU DON'T HAVE.
TO I MISS MISTER.
I'M SORRY MR SANTIAGO MY
EYESIGHT MUST BE BAD AT IT SORRY
I AM TRYING TO JUST GET THROUGH
THESE SO.
MR SANTIAGO I DIDN'T SEE YOU.
YOU HAVE -- TWO BILLS THAT
YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT ON EIGHTY
FOUR OH SEVEN IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE
BILL WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS CREO
TO SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK ARE
SUCH AN **** AND I BOTH FOR A.
B. -- FOUR OH SEVEN SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT RIGHT SPENCER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUT ASK MEDICAL
SAFETY ASSOCIATION WITH SPONSORS
OF THE BILL IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO AB FIVE SIXTY IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION THE
BILL A MOTION BY MS CREE ON A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
ARE SUCH AN AWESOME AYE VOTE.
WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF
MY CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NO FILE.
ALL RIGHT -- THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL WITH MR FONG
[inaudible]
THIRTY NINE NO
ON AGAIN THAT DOES GET OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL WITH MR FUNG
SUPPORTING.
AND MR BIGELOW NOT VOTING.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE SOME AUTHORS
HERE NOW -- MISTER BERMAN.
AND IT LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE TO
BILLS AB ELEVEN FORTY SIX IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THE ANIME MOTION BY A DOCTOR
QUIRK IN A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO THANK YOU I I UNDERSTAND
YOU'VE ASKED FOR VERY THOROUGH
ANALYSES OF THE BILLS BY THE
PRESENTERS -- SO AB ELEVEN FORTY
SIX IS A VERY GOOD BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OF A THAT
WAS BETTER THAN BREAKING A PLATE
ON MY FOOT.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT OF CASA
BEHALF CALIFORNIA CAR DEALERS
SPONSORED THE BILL THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DON'T WRITE FAST.
A LORD YES SUPPORT WORKERS ON
THE OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
BERMAN FINANCE THE FILE.
SEEN NO COMMENTS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
OUT ON A ROLL CALL FOR THE
RECORD IT WAS AN ACCIDENT.
YEAH THAT'S WHAT YOU SAY NOW.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR IT ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MS CARILLO A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK MAKE THIS
ONE LESS PAINFUL -- MADAM CHAIR
AB FIFTEEN SIXTY FOUR WHAT A LOT
OF THE BUSINESS COVER ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIANS WERE PROJECT
MAINTAINING THEIR TOLL FREE
PHONE NUMBER OR EMAIL ADDRESS IN
A PHYSICAL ADDRESS FOR CONSUMERS
EXERCISE THE RIGHTS.
OF THE CECE'S PA IT'S ALSO GOOD
BILL I RESPECT AS PRIVATE.
AWESOME SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
KEVIN KELLY WITH INTERNET
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR CHRIS MCKINLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
GREAT SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NO FILE.
IRATE THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU MENTOR.
AT WE ONE OUNCE AB TWO FORTY TO
AND GETS OUT [inaudible]
A COMMITTEE.
WITH THE REAP HOW ON AND WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING AND
MISTER DEEP VOTING HI.
MR HOLDEN IS NOT.
HOW DO I MISS YOU?
I WAS LOOKING FOR THE SEATS
COMMA AND MR HOLDEN AB TWELVE
TWENTY SIX IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THE BILL THE
MOTION IS MOVED BY MISS KOREA
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- THIS BILL IS -- FRAME
DOES THINKING OUTSIDE THE BOX --
CALIFORNIA'S FACING A CRIPPLING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SHORTAGE AND
HAS THE LARGEST POPULATION OF
AND SHELTERED PEOPLE IN THE
NATION.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ALONE HAS
RECORDED FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THE
HIGH COST OF LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA MAKES IT NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR SOMEONE THAT HAS
LOST HER HOME THE FINAL TURN OF
HOUSING IN THEIR SAME
NEIGHBORHOOD.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS RAPID
MUST EXPLORE ALL TOOLS AVAILABLE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE TWENTY SIX
WILL STUDY THE FEASIBILITY OF
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING OVER BELOW
GRADE HIGHWAYS I RESPECTFULLY US.
THANK YOU SUPPORTERS.
ANY FOLKS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
I SEE NO COMMENTS.
THAT GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS
NOT THIRTY MISTER DEEP MISTER
OBERNOLTE VOTING HI.
WE HAVE A SECOND FILLED MR
HOLDEN NO YOU DO NOT THAT'S IT
IT'S ON CONSENT.
THEY'RE THEY'RE MESSING WITH ME
OVER HERE [inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
MR MEDINA YOUR I'M SORRY --
YOU'RE NOT ONLY GOING TO BE VOTE
AND PRESENTING A SUSPENSE BILL
BUT YOU WEREN'T NEXT IN LINE I'M
SORRY SO SO YOU MISTER TEEN.
MISTER KING IS PRESENTING ON AB
SIX NINETY SEVEN IT ENJOYS EIGHT
TO PASS AS AMENDED WITH A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET MOVE THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION WITH THE AMENDMENT
FROM IS CREEL IN A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FIRST
IMAGES THANK YOU IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME I'M TAKING THE AMENDMENT FOR
THE FIVE YEAR SUNSET -- OUR BILL
REQUIRES COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITY
THAT RECEIVE CAL GRANTS. TO
PUBLISHED FARE -- DATA AROUND
LEGACY AND ALUMNI ADMISSIONS I
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR CHAIR OF
HIGHER EDUCATION FOR WORKING
WITH US ON THIS BILL.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FIVE OF THANK
YOU -- SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
WE HAVE A MOTION I JUST WANT TO
INSURE WE HAD A ROBUST
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS -- WITH
OUR STAFF AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY UNDERSTANDS THAT
ALTHOUGH BE REPORTED THERE WILL
BE NO STUDENT NAMES REPORTED OR
THAT WILL BE ALLOWED TO BE.
GIVEN OUT.
IT WAS JUST LOOKING AT OVERALL
DATA YES THANK YOU -- WITH THAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THIS RESPECT AS RIVAL AND THAT'S
GOING TO GO ON CALL AND SINCE WE
GET ONE MORE DEMOCRAT ON THE
COMMITTEE HERE WE CAN GET SOME
OF THESE BILLS OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SORRY MR MEDINA MISTER CHU HAS
ARRIVED THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN YOU WANT TO PRESENT ON
SUSPENSE [inaudible]
MISTER GILL.
MISTER CHAIR -- IS -- PRESENT
PRESENTING ON AB SEVEN ELEVEN IT
DOES I HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION MOVE THE BILL.
A MOTION -- BY MISS CREEL AS
SECOND BY A I HAD MR QUIRK.
WILL BE INCREDIBLY BRIEF IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL TO ALLOW TRANSGENDER
NON BINARY PEOPLE ARE NO LONGER
IN SCHOOL TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
UPDATE OLD -- EDUCATION RECORDS --
AND WOULD CLOSE A CURRENT GAP IN
THE LAW CURRENTLY CURRENT
STUDENTS CAN HAVE -- THEIR
RECORDS ADJUSTED BUT NOT
GRADUATE SO -- WITH THAT TURN
OVER TWO QUICK WITNESSES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ALICE
KESSLER HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
QUALITY CALIFORNIA OVER THE
SPONSOR THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU -- SPEAK ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
NO FILE.
I SEE NO SPEAKERS FROM.
THE COMMITTEE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT THAT GETS OUT ON A B.
ROLL CALL WITH MR OBERNOLTE
VOTING I AM MR FONG AND MR YET
NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE ONE OF THE RIGHT. TWO
ITEMS ON CONSENTS TO AN OBJECT
EXPENSE AND GAME BE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A MOTION
BY MISS KOREA IN A SECOND BY
DOCTOR QUIRK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THIS IS
A COMMITTEE THAT WELL KNOWS NOT
JUST A HOUSING CRISIS WERE IN
BUT THE TEN CRISIS WITH MILLIONS
OF TENANTS THAT ARE ONE RENT
INCREASE AWAY -- FROM NOT BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD BASIC NECESSITIES
ARE BECOMING HOMELESSNESS -- WE
ALSO HAVE HEARD MANY MANY
STORIES OF TENANTS FACING
SIGNIFICANT RENT HIKES THIS IS A
BILL THAT'S PART OF A SOLUTION.
IT'S NOT RENT CONTROL BUT IT
WOULD APPLY IN ANTI RENT GOUGING
POLICY THAT WOULD BE DESIGNED TO
PROTECT FIFTEEN MILLION TENANTS
WHO DOES NOT HAVE RENT CONTROL.
AGAINST THE MOST EGREGIOUS RENT
INCREASES WHILE ALLOWING
LANDLORDS TO MAKE A FAIR RETURN
ON OUR INVESTMENT.
THE BILL WOULD ESTABLISH A CAP
ON THE ANNUAL RENT INCREASE OF
CPI PLUS 5% -- SINCE THE AVERAGE
CPI'S ABOUT TWO AND A HALF
PERCENT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
MAXIMUM INCREASE OF SEVEN AND A
HALF 28%.
THIS IS A FORMULA IT'S BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF DATA POINTS --
WHICH I COULD EXPLAIN IF ANYONE
WOULD LIKE -- WANTED JUST CLOSE
BY SAYING AS I COMMITTED IN THE
ASSEMBLY HOUSING COMMITTEE
WORKING HARD TO FIND COMMON
GROUND BETWEEN THE TWO SIDES AND
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS BY THE
OPPOSITION.
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
EVERYONES WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
IN CONSTRUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS ON
THIS BILL AND WITH THAT HOUSE --
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO MOVE THIS
[inaudible]
FOR ALL.
GOOD IN SUPPORT GOOD MORNING
ANOTHER WITH THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY ONE OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MANAGER MEMBERS AS EARLY AS WE
HAVE THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
TRANSPORT.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS TIONNE
INSTITUTING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND I'M ALSO
HERE IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- RUBBER COPELAND
SECOND ATTENTION STRONG SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- CREAM GREASY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS -- AT
ITS BUSINESS MEETINGS THIS PAST
WEEK THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS ADOPTED IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO TWO IN
TANDEM WITH THIS POLICY SEE OUR
IS ALSO ESTABLISHING AN INTERNAL --
RENTAL HOUSING LEGISLATIVE
ADVISORY GROUP -- WHICH WILL
ALLOW SEE OUR TO NEGOTIATE IN
REAL TIME ON THIS MEASURE --
WITH THIS POSITION AS WELL AS
THE AFOREMENTIONED ADVISORY
GROUP.
SEE OUR WILL ENGAGE IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR THE
SPONSORS AND STAFF.
OUR HOPE IS THAT THESE
DISCUSSIONS WILL BE PRODUCTIVE
AND RESULT IN A MINUTES BEING
INCORPORATED INTO THE BILL THAT
SEEK TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
US HERE LOOKS FOR TO WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AS WELL AS
THE LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE AS IT
EXPLORES VARIOUS PUBLIC POLICY
OPTIONS THAT SEEKS TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH CARL TO THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
WITH THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CONTINUED TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH US.
AS YOU HEARD OF MANY OF YOU IN
THE HOUSING COMMITTEE WE WANT TO
JUST MAKE SURE THAT A WEEK
CREATE SOME STABILITY IN THE
MARKET PLACE WE DON'T WANT TO
SCARE OFF CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE
THAT OF COURSE IS OUR BIGGEST
CONCERN -- IN THE MARKET PLACES
THAT WE CONTINUE TO BUILD NEW
HOUSING BECAUSE WE THINK THAT IS
THE BEST THING. FOR THE TEN A
COMMUNITY -- BUT WHEN IT COMES
TO PROVIDING SAFE PLACES TO LIVE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
AT WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ECHO THE COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION THANKS [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
WHICH I CLOSE.
A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR THE
SUPPORTED ME.
RIGHT THAT -- WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO PUT ON CALL WE NEED ONE MORE.
MR BONTA MISTER CALDERON MR
GABRIEL TO SHOW UP -- BUT WE'LL
TAKE THAT UP ONCE ONE OF THEM
GETS HERE THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU.
I'M AT THIS POINT WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A COUPLE BILLS OFF CALL I'M
AB TWO FORTY ONE BY MISS COME
LIKE OUR JOB.
BUT GETS.
OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VERY MISTER DEPUTY NO AB TWO SIX
NINETY SEVEN MISTER TEAM GETS
OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING.
ALL RIGHT MISTER MEDINA YOU'RE
GONNA PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE BELL.
AND YOU DON'T EVEN HAVE KIDS
HERE.
SO THAT THAT MAKES IT ONE LAST
THE MISTER BLOOM THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I FEEL OF THIS MORNING.
TODAY PRESENT AB THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM IS OUTDATED
AND OVERLY COMPLEX WITH TOO MANY
BARRIERS TO ACCESS STATE AID
DOES NOT ADEQUATELY SERVE
TODAY'S COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AND DOES NOT REFLECT THE HIGH
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA.
AB THIRTEEN FOURTEEN MAKES MUCH
NEEDED COMPREHENSIVE REFORMS TO
THE CAL GRANT PROGRAM TO MAKE
OUR SYSTEM MORE EQUITABLE AND TO
ENSURE MORE CALIFORNIANS HAVE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE FINANCIAL AID STAKEHOLDERS
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PROCESS AND WILL CONTENT TEN YOU
TO WORK WITH THEM.
AS WE CONTINUE TO FLESH OUT THE
DETAILS AND THE PHASE IN OF THIS
CRITICAL LEGISLATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
NO FILE.
I'M SO GLAD YOU PRESENT ON THAT
I NOW UNDERSTAND THE BILL SO
MUCH BETTER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
I LOVE YOU MISTER MEDINA.
ALL RIGHT MISTER KALRA.
MISTER KALRA YOU'RE PRESSING ON
AB EIGHTEEN OH FIVE IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE ARE MOTION BY MS CARILLO IN A
SECOND BY A MISTER RIVAS -- I'M
SORRY BY MISTER COOK DR QUIRK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THESE A
TECHNICAL CHANGES REQUESTED BY
CAL OSHA -- THEY'LL BRING
LANGUAGE IN LINE.
WITH FEDERAL OSHA STANDARDS
INCREASING FOR UNIFORMLY THEY
BECAUSE OF PAST WHEN I LOOK.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
LOW THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL
CALL WITH MR GET READY.
NINE FIND A CLOSE FORM.
MISS BURKE I'M SORRY NOW WE CAN
FINALLY GET TO AND MISS BURKE
THAT IS AN EIGHT FORTY AB EIGHT
FORTY SIX ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION THE BILL WE HAVE
A MOTION BY MS PREOWNED A SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRK AB EIGHT FORTY
SIX CLARIFIES THE CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT.
IS NOT INTENDED TO PROHIBIT
BUSINESS FROM OFFERING KIND
CUSTOMER LOYALTY PROGRAMS WITH
THAT I WILL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN ITEM.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
EDUCATION SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT SERVER WITH
CAL CHAMBER IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS KAYLEE FOR
COUNTY AND SUPPORT.
KATIE HAD SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU ARE THERE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO
FILE.
THANK YOU THANK IT'S OUT ON ANY
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
[inaudible]
MISTER NAZARIAN.
YOU ARE PRESENTING ON AB TWELVE
OH NINE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE BILL MUCH MY
MISCREANT A SECOND BY DOCTOR
QUIRK.
THANK YOU -- AB TWELVE OH NINE
ADDRESSES THE LONG TERM CARE
EXPENSES HI BUT POLICIES AND
WITH THAT I ASKED FOR APPLE.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
NO COMMENTS THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN THANK YOU AB TOLD.
EIGHTY SEVEN I THOUGHT I HAD TO
THAT THAT IS -- ON SUSPENSE -- I
DON'T KNOW WAS I THOUGHT IT
SEVEN ONE SEVEN THAT'S ON
SUSPENSE.
THEY'RE BOTH ON SUSPENSE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
NAZARIAN.
MR FRAZIER WELL NOW WAIT WAIT
WAIT I DON'T HAVE AN UPDATED.
LIST OF WHO CAME HERE FIRST SO
MISTER JOHN SORRY MR FRAZIER DO
YOU GUYS KNOW WHO GOT HERE FIRST.
MISTER JONES SAWYER ALRIGHT.
MISTER JOHN JONES SAWYER HOLD
HOLD OKAY.
YOU.
AB.
TWELVE NINETY ONE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE WERE MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
WE HAVE A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB TWELVE
NINETY ONE CLARIFIES THE TIME
FRAME FOR WHEN CANNABIS
BUSINESSES NEED TO COMPLY WITH
LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT
REQUIREMENTS AB TWELVE NINETY
ONE WILL REQUIRE BUSINESSES WITH
TWENTY EMPLOYEES OR MORE.
ENTER A LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OR A THEIR
TWENTIETH PLOY E..
OB ACCORDING TO THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS TO COST ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BILL ARE NEGLIGIBLE WITH ME
TODAY.
IT NO ONE RIGHT NOW SO.
THAT'S HOW YOU GOT IT YOU GOT
SUPPORTER BACK THERE.
MR CHERRY CAM IS A OUR SPECS
ASKED RIVALS THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF MEMBERS AGREEABLE
TO RECALL THE AFTER UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS PUNCH THE
BILL SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
IN A FINANCE NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS LIKE IT'S OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU
MISTER JONESSAWYER THANK YOU
MISTER FOR L. FRAZIER.
COMING UP.
AT MISTER FRAZIER HAS AB TEN
EIGHTEEN IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I WE HAVE MEASURE
BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN THE SECOND BY
MISS KOREA THANK YOU MANAGER AB.
ONE TEN EIGHTEEN CODIFIES HOME
PRISONERS MUST STAY WITHIN THEIR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE WHEN
DETERMINING A HOME VALUATION I
RESPECT LAST RIVAL.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT AND I'M SURE
MEMBERS MIGHT BELOW FOR THE
APPRAISAL INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THIS REQUEST RIVAL THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL WITH MR OBERNOLTE
NOT VOTING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MANAGER THANK YOU MISTER FRAZIER
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
WE CAN OUTSIDE AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO BY MR CHIU BOUGHT OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR GAP
NOT VOTING MISS PETRIE-NORRIS
NOT VOTING.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM.
AB THIRTEEN OH EIGHT YOU HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON A. B. THIRTY NO IT THANK YOU
THAT'S WAY TO DO IT.
SUPPORTERS.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THAT GETS OUT ON AND A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTER CUNNINGHAM
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA GO TO
COMMITTEE MEMBER SINCE I SEE
NÁN NO ONE IN THE AUDIENCE
MISS KOREA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT AB.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WE HAVE
AND MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A
SECOND BY MISTER GARCIA.
AS FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
VENTURA RECESS OR THE OTHER WE
HAVE THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THAT GETS OUT ON B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR GET BUDDING YES HI SORRY.
MAKE IT UP THAT'S ALL RIGHT --
WELL.
MISS LOW MOAN.
COME ON DOWN.
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THE MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK IN A
SECOND BY MISS KOREA AS QUICKLY
AS WHEN I HAVE A OTHERS SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
THIS IS THE END OF A LEAVE FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAVE YOU EVER
SIR OVER THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
BUT SHEPHERD ON BEHALF OF THE
NONPROFIT ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT -- DEPARTMENT FINANCE
[inaudible]
THE FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
THERE'S A CLASS.
THANK YOU CHECK IT OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MR FONG NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU.
MR MANGE ANY PRESENTING FOR MR
LEVINE.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION IT'S A
MISTER LEVIN'S BILL MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN IS DOING HIM A FAVOR.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR
REQUIRES A CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES TO CONTRACT
WITH NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES TO
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS AND NON
MINERS.
CURRENTLY IN FOSTER CARE THEIR
MINOR IN HIS OR WILL COST
ASSOCIATE WITH THIS BILL
THINKING RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AND I ABOUT.
THANK YOU -- SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE
THAT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR GET NOT VOTING.
ALRIGHT MR RIVAS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO GO.
AB TWELVE SIXTY SIX YES TWO
BILLS -- THIS IS ROBERT RIVAS AB
TWELVE SIXTY SIX AS ENJOY THE DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION OF THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MYSTERY --
AND A SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- TWELVE
SIXTY SIX IT'S A BILL THAT WOULD
CLARIFY -- IN THAT SHARED BY CAN
RIGHT TURN LANES ARE LEGAL IN
THE STATE AND WOULD REQUIRE
CALTRANS -- TO DID DID DEVELOP A
STANDARD LANE MARKINGS APPOINTED
ANALYSIS COSTS ARE MINOR AND
OBSERVABLE.
BECAUSE IN SUPPORT.
WHEN THE COMMISSION WITH A
CALIFORNIA BICYCLE COALITION
SPONSOR OF THE BILL THANK YOU?
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE FILE.
OUR RATE THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MR BIGELOW MR FONG NOT
VOTING.
YOUR NEXT BILL IS AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AB SIXTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT LAST YEAR ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOBBY ERR.
BUT THERE ARE STEPS TO BE OVER
OF THE VINYL JUSTICE OF THIS
BILL DO TWO THINGS IT WOULD ONE
INCLUDE THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL HIS OFFICE THAT THIS NEW
BUREAU.
WOULD BE INCLUDED ON THE LIST OF
AGENCIES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH MUST
COORDINATE WITH REGARDING --
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE SECOND IT ALSO EXPANDS
THE DEFINITION OF A PRIMAL JUST
INCLUDE THE MEANINGFUL CASEMENT
OF IMPACTED COMMUNITIES.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
YOU KNOW AS AS WITH CALIFORNIA
ROOM TO JUST.
SPONSOR THE BILLING TRANSPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE -- RESPECT
LAST NIGHT OF THAT GETS OUT WITH
THE B. ROLL CALL WITH MR D. UP
NOT VOTING.
THEY CAN AFTER I AM GOING TO
PRESENT MY BILLS AT THIS TIME IF
THAT'S OKAY MISTER BIGELOW.
NO NOT YET.
I DO NOT SEE MR CHANNEL -- NO
****.
ALRIGHT I WILL PRESENT MY BILLS
AND AND I'M SURE YOU HAVE AB.
FIVE FOUR SEVEN I UNDERSTAND
THIS AS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WELL THE BILL SECOND WE HAVE A
MOTION AND WE HAVE A SECOND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
HE IS HUSTLING QUICKLY.
READ ABOUT US HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA AS FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER SINCE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING LOWER CURTIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED
TODAY WE ARE CONCERNED WITH THE
BILL WITH REGARDS TO FISCAL
EFFECTS BECAUSE IT SETS THE ITS
STATUTORILY REQUIRES THE PURE
TRAINERS HAVE A SET.
STANDARD TO PAY AS WELL AS
REQUIRES THAT THE HIRING ENTITY --
HIGHER FROM A LIST OF A
QUALIFIED TRAINERS THAT WOULD
DRIVE UP COSTS IN JANITORIAL
INDUSTRY.
ADDITIONALLY THESE THAT THEY
DEPARTMENT HAS REGULATIONS
CURRENTLY.
PROPOSED ON THIS ISSUE AS WELL
AS A TRAILER BILL SO WE THINK
THAT THIS IS ADAM A LITTLE BIT
AHEAD OF ITS TIME.
AND FOR THESE REASONS WE OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY ONE ELSE
SAYING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
NO FILE -- MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE AUTHOR SEEN ON THIS BILL
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH
MR DEEP VOTING I AM IS
PETRIE-NORRIS NOT VOTING.
YOU HAVE AB.
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN MANAGER AS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION YES.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ASK WHERE I MET WITH A HOW A
CLIENT REQUESTS.
FOR NINE THAT'S GREAT.
VERY CONCISE.
SUPPORT WOULD YOU LIKE 2%
RESPONSIBLE.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE CHIRLA
COLLISION REMAINING RIGHTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
NO I BOTTOM -- WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION SEEING NO
NE RALLY TO THE CALL DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE NO FILE.
THANK YOU -- QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR SEEN NINE THIS GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL WITH MR DEEP
NOT VOTING.
WE'RE STILL LOOKING FOR AUTHOR.
AUTHORS MR CHOW [inaudible]
MR CHILD.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBER.
IN THE MEANTIME I'LL TAKE A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE THE MOTION BY MISTER CORREO
IN A SECOND BY A DOCTOR QUIRK
AMOUNTS OF TREE WE READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
AB 254-340-9440 659-728-7798
489-294-0990 710-261-07211
321-161-1160 411-661-16811
991-278-1290. 1-299-111-3213
701-376-1370 914-841-49715
351-561-1570 316-661-70918
002-181-01813 EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FIVE EIGHTEEN
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT ACR FIFTY AND A C. R..
SEVENTY EIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION
SECOND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
AT THIS POINT.
WE WILL READ -- THE BILLS THAT
ARE BEING MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE
FILE WHERE AUTHORS HAVE WAIVED
PRESENTATION -- MADAM SECRETARY.
WOULD YOU READ THE SUSPENSE FILE.
AB 233-840-3407 505-667-1241
251-261-34130 916-166-1672
1-723-235-2382 752-892-91290.
632-433-2340 434-053-31370
1-378-353-9540 414-434-4374
422-474-47740 SIX FIVE TWENTY
ONE BY THIRTY FOUR FIVE TWO TWO
TWO BY THE TWO FIVE FIVE SEVENTY
FIVE NINETY FOUR BY MANY EIGHT
SIX WELL. 617-696-4026
716-736-8470 717-721-7247
474-017-4027 447-227-8760 FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN THREE SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN EIGHT OR ONE EIGHT SIXTEEN
TWENTY TWO AND 313-283-06050
SEVEN A 759-069-08911
919-939-58960. ONE NINE SIX
THREE NINE SEVENTY NINE SEVENTY
ONE NINE EIGHTY SIX CHANNEL
FOURTEEN TEN TEN SIXTEEN TEN
TWENTY TEN TWENTY TWO TEN TWENTY
FIVE TO TEN TWENTY EIGHT TO
THIRTY SIX TO FORTY SIX AND
491-057-1060 EIGHT TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT TO NINETY EIGHT AND THEN
AT SIXTEEN ELEVEN SEVENTEEN
ELEVEN TWENTY SIX ELEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT ELEVEN THIRTY ELEVEN
THIRTY ONE ELEVEN THIRTY FOR
THEM. 531-172-1170 311-821-19111
961-200-1217 1-224-122-7203.
943-212-3612 621-279-1280
712-952-9613 FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
TWENTY FIVE THIRTEEN TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO
THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE THIRTEEN
FIFTY SIX THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN SIXTY FIVE THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE FORTINO ONE FORTINO.
514-092-2414 545-914-6040.
641-454-06614 791-483-1480.
714-991-5515 615-815-1115
341-540-51540 815-505-0682
788-015-8315 891-596-1608.
SIXTEEN THIRTY ONE SIXTEEN FIFTY
THREE SIXTEEN SIXTY THREE
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT FIFTEEN
SEVENTY TWO SIXTEEN SEVENTY SIX
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIXTEEN EIGHTY FOUR SIXTY
SEVEN SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE
SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR SIXTEEN
NINETY SIX SEVENTY NO
217-031-71117. SEVENTEEN
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TO SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN FIFTY
THREE SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR
SEVENTEEN SIXTY SEVEN SIX
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY THREE SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR SEVENTEEN NINETY SIX
SEVENTEEN NINETY NINE EIGHTEEN
OH SIX YOU KNOW SEVEN EIGHT YOU
KNOW. EIGHT EIGHT ZERO NINE
EIGHT ZERO SIX FOUR THANK YOU AS
YOU CAN SEE THAT WAS A HUGE LIST
I WANT TO FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY
HEART THANK EVERY AUTHOR WHO
WAVED PRESENTATION -- MAKES IT
FOR A QUICKER MEETING.
AT HOWEVER IF YOU ARE HERE IN
THE AUDIENCE AND YOU HAD HOPED
TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION TO ONE OF THOSE BILLS
THAT HAVE -- THE OTHERS WAIT
PRESENTATION YOU MAY GO TO THE
MICROPHONE AND DO SO NOW -- SEE
NOBODY [inaudible]
ARE YOU [inaudible]
YOUR GUIDE [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE ARE WAITING ON MR
CHOW FOR OUR FINAL BILL
.
THANK YOU DOCTOR QUIRK IS GOING
TO PRESENT ON BEHALF OF MR CHOW
IT'S AB [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY TWO DOCTOR
QUIRK -- MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MS CARILLO --
IT'S A GREAT BILL -- AS FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU DO WE HAVE
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
BUT I'M SURE MEMBERS CHORUS ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION ON POLICY GROUNDS.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NO FILE.
THAT GETS OUT IN A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR FONG NOT VOTING THANK
YOU DOCTOR QUIRK AND THANK YOU
ALL THAT CONCLUDES -- THE THIS
WEEK'S.
APPROPRIATIONS HEARING. FIVE
MINUTES BEFORE THE BETTING TIME